jours heureux évidemment imite vous
retrouver vraiment ça me touche beaucoup
ça me va droit au coeur votre accueil et
c'est le cas de le dire
alors merci je ne sais pas si pendant
cette longue et douloureuse parenthèse
vivement dimanche vous a manqué mais
vous m'avez beaucoup manqué et merci
pour tous vos témoignages
et sincèrement je pensais que je
disparaîtrai à jamais des radars ils
m'ont dit tu vas rester
on va disposer des best-of tu prends ton
temps six mois huit mois le temps qu'il
faudra qu'on te garde ta place et oui et
michel voilà comme j'ai dit je vais
envoyer un petit message jeudi le patron
est revenu ça m'a fait extrêmement
plaisir de revoir michel drucker et qui
a cartonné en audience comme quoi voilà
il avait manqué aux téléspectateurs qui
nous avait manqué il y en a aussi à
qu'il avait moqué c'est gad elmaleh
puisque mon frère ont été invités chez
michel effet son titre était très ému
gad elmaleh de revoir michel drucker sur
un plat pour regarder puis très heureux
de te voir ici et très très émue aussi
depuis ce matin je pense à devan que
j'avais envie de faire dès que j'allais
rentrer le fait de voir ici après tout
ce temps je ça va prendre un petit en
avant 2 avant de les faire et c'est vrai
que on a plus parlé un peu pendant ce
moment qui était difficile pour toi
j'essaie de te faire rire parfois non on
va dire les vraies choses michel je
pense que tu as orchestré un coup de
communication énorme tas disparu tu
reviens tu fais espèce de come-back
rothau come back dans ta carrière je
sais pas comment tu fais ça tu es très
fort il est magnifique à michel drucker
ça vous a fait plaisir de le revoir
oui c'est extrêmement émouvant et vous
savez qu'il ait accordé une interview au
parisien ce week-end michel drucker et
on lui a demandé quels sont les
animateurs qui l'impressionnait plus et
vous en faites partie basse a appelé
news a cité avec christophe dechavanne
notamment bah ça m'a fait marrer et
cyril féraud je croyais le giro
exactement énormément et c'est
christophe christophe qui m'a envoyé
d'ailleurs le le monde un petit message
en disant ça ça lui a fait plaisir aussi
à christophe dechavanne
voilà et c'est vrai que ça m'a fait
plaisir quand c'est michel drucker qui
disent ah c'est vrai que voilà c'est
phénoménal
non monsieur d'origine benjamin castaldi
disait que j'avais des beaux yeux
toutes les missions de tirs nourris je
vous jure que ça vous l'aï paire de
lunettes à dire elle est au top gun
bonjour des baux tiffany les pas beaux
gosses comme ça en plus a sorti avec la
chemise et le teint bien aller je trouve
très bon d'accord vous me demanderez de
ne pas trop vous donner l'accord
[Rires]